πιέχει τα θέματα τα δικά της δηλαδή έει χάσει τα τελευταία χρόνια της συνοχή της
τ έχουμε δεί καιστις κρίσεις του δεκατρία δηλαδή πρι μια δικαϊτία το έχουμε δκες τις
αντιδράσεις όσον αφορά το κόβει δλαδή γενικότερα οι ευρώ οποι έχει χάσει της συνοχήτης όπως
έχει χάσει και στους κλίμα καις ανταγωνιστικότητας και καινοτομίας έχει μείνει πίσω σε θέματα και
νοδομίας θα πρέπει να ξαναυρείτον ε αυτό της να επανασχεδιάσει κάποια θέματα έχουμε δεί το
θέμα τις πράσις μετάβασεης το έχουμε μιλήσει προηγουμένως ότι νέατεράστιο βαρίδιο για τες οικονομίες όλοι
βεβαίως θέλουμε μια ναπάμε ενάνδια στην κληματιγια νααβει που θα έρθει πο θα έθει κε
αναδρομικά βεβαίως και πολλές φορές οι ευρώπι προσπαθούσε να είναι η πρώτη που θα θέσει
αυστηρούς στόχους που μεγαλεπίβολους στόχους αλλά σοτο θέναθο έλως της ημέρας ποιο θα πληρώσει τον
λογαριασμό είαι ευρωπαίος πολίτης και ευρωαίος πολί τς θα δει πρώταδοδικό του οικονομικό συμφέρω όταν
δεν μπορεί να βγάλει τα προς το ζι και βεβαίως θα πάει με κινήματα που
είναι ενάντια σε αυτά που έχουν συμφωνηθεί άρα ο κάθε το κάθε ευρωπαως πολίτης αυτή
τη στιγμή κατανο ότι κάποιο έχουν αποφασίσει στις βριξέλλες στο στρασβούργο κάποια πράγματα εμένα δε
με απασχολούν ναι θέλω να είμαι φιλικός προς το περιβάλλο αλλά στο λεύς της σημέρας
αν δεν τα βγάζω με τα παιδιά τα παιδιά μου κγαι δομέλλομού ας μίνει στο
πλάει την ίδια στιγμή που υπόλειπες χώρες δεν τιρούν αυτά που έπρεπε να τηρίσουν καιοτόν
αλτράείναι προτεργάτης στο να πάει ενάντια στους οποιος δήποτεασόποιοδήποτε συμφωνίες έχουν έχουν τεθείείται είναι για
την παγκόσημια κληματική αλλαγή είτα για δημαγκόσμι εγεί γενικότερα θέλει να έχει πλήραν εξαρτησία να
κάνει αυτά που ο ίδιος πιστέρη σε προσε να άλλο θέμα και θα ξανάρθουμε ανότερε
εκπαίρευση στην κύπρο τη γνωρίσ από πρότοχ